no matter how you use Google cloud
platform we have tools to help you get
things done quickly and easily and this
short video will cover the cloud SDK the
g-cloud command line and cloud shell the
cloud console our integrated web-based
Google cloud platform management web UI
is a great place to start using GCP it
offers powerful and centralized site to
manage all of your resources projects
and billing information and you should
check out the video link below for more
details
next we'll talk about the command-line
developer and admin tools let's start
with Cloud SDK cloud SDK is a set of
command line tools including g-cloud GS
util and BQ which you can use to access
compute engine cloud storage bigquery
and other products from the command line
you can run these tools interactively or
in your automated scripts cloud SDK is
supported on Linux Mac OS and Windows
and requires Python to run you can
install via apt-get or yum or by using
an installer and interactive or non
interactive mode once installed the SDK
supports updates and additional features
as we'll see in a minute we'll also talk
about how not to install cloud SDK later
in this video the most used part of
cloud SDK is G cloud and the typical
first command after installation is
g-cloud init to perform setup tasks this
takes care of both authorizing Cloud SDK
tools to use your user account
credentials to access your DCP resources
as well as setting up a configuration
which covers the active account the
current project and optionally the
default compute engine region and zone
you can rerun this command at a later
time to change your settings or to
create a new configuration you can view
the current configuration at any time
using the G cloud config list command
managing and updating Cloud SDK is also
done using G cloud by default the SDK
installs G cloud commands that are
generally available or GA additional
functionality is available as SDK
components named alpha and beta and can
be installed using the G cloud
components installed command updates the
existing components are achieved with
g-cloud components update once installed
and configured you can achieve virtually
anything with GTL that you can do with
cloud console in fact when using cloud
console you're often able to obtain the
equivalent g-cloud command for what you
are doing in the graphical interface
manage VMs and storage buckets setup and
networking and firewalls built and test
locally deploy to production monitor
logs it can all be done with G cloud and
all of this can be automated in scripts
and in first code or CI CD tools for a
richer more interactive experience as
you type Auto completion is available
via an interactive mode check it out
it works with G cloud but also with the
other command line tools in the SDK for
those windows powershell users out there
do not feel left out as we have cloud
tools for powershell this set of command
lets for powershell will let you manage
GCB resources in a way that should feel
familiar let's now switch to cloud shell
wouldn't it be nice if you had an always
available browser-based environment with
g cloud what if it also came with all
your favorite tools such as git bash
built-in package tools docker cube CTL
your language specific tools text
editors etc this is precisely what cloud
shell offers a temporary g1 small
virtual machine running a Debian image
hosted on GCP with all these tools
always up to date it comes with five
gigabytes of persistent disk storage for
your scripts source files dot files and
for your own binaries
there's even a built in web editor with
support for Java Go Python node Ruby PHP
and dotnet core all of this from a
simple web browser best of all it's free
Kyle shell can be used to run g-cloud
commands only without having to install
update or configure it authorization to
GCP projects and resources is also built
in cloud shell can also be used as a
development environment
with its web preview mode which enables
a browser to access a web server running
on cloud shell app engines local sdk for
instance cloud shell also has some
advanced features the boost mode option
will provide you with a larger and one
standard one VM instance for 24 hours
thus enabling better CPU and memory
cloud shell uses T mocks by default
which is great to reconnect to in
running session in a new browser window
but also to split the window into left
and right panes for debugging purposes
also if you'd like to customize the
environment with additional tools you
can provide your own docker image a few
additional things to know first a cloud
shell session terminates after one hour
of inactivity then any modification that
you've done outside of your home
directory are lost when the instance is
terminated otherwise use the
customization feature that I've
mentioned finally if you do not access
cloud shell for 120 days your home disk
will be deleted with our Cloud SDK and
cloud shell you should have all the
developer and management tools needed to
go build something awesome ready go if
you like this video please like
subscribe comment share and look forward
to more GCP essentials videos
you